thank you
there are places in Miami where people
go to let their hair down
the acts of Escape when confrontation
Comes To Town
but the prosecution of Donald Trump
won't change their world you just look
at the past couple years nothing changed
people's you know
so why would this be any different I'm
happy that he is actually being indicted
for crimes he probably committed okay I
mean there's evidence he committed them
so
I just didn't think it was ever going to
happen
the prosecution of the former president
has shocked many in Florida the state
votes Republican and it votes for Donald
Trump and there are those who think the
government is out to get him
but on Ocean Drive
people see things in a different way
at the world famous Palace drag show
people say the former president doesn't
speak to and hasn't spoken up for them
what do you make of Donald Trump
if I don't care you don't see it I don't
I I don't unfortunately like we have we
have we have someone that is against our
community and as you can see we are we
are not hurting anybody and we are about
love and we are about accepted and we
just want to be here and live life the
way
not everybody wants to live their lives
fully
[Music]
[Applause]
90 minutes up the road we found
different performers on a very different
stage this event hosted by club 47 part
of Donald Trump's so-called base
[Applause]
and the featured speaker aspiring office
holder Kerry Lake
Trump is a warrior
a warrior
he's Godzilla
and they're just little tiny geckos
running around
Trump's indictment the product of Joe
Biden's fearful regime she said and we
didn't see anyone objecting I
Donald J Trump
I wonder what people will think when
they see boxes of government records in
the storage room his shower room his
bedroom other rooms it doesn't play well
well I think he doesn't play well for
Joe Biden either who has him in his
garage
if the former presidents made mistakes
the Democrats have done worse
on the Republicans of Florida well they
have a nation to save John Sparks Sky
News Miami Beach